بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله واشهد ان لا اله
الا الله واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين اما بعد
فتكمله
لحديث ابي سعيد الخدري رضي الله عنه
في باب التوبه من رياض الصالحين
ابو سعيد الخدري
رياض الصالحين
ابو سعيد سعد ابن مالك ابن سنان الخدري
صلى الله عليه
سعد ابن مالك
سعد بن مالك
ابو سعيد
name
رضي الله عنه سعد بن ابي وقاس
سعد بن مالك
بن مالك ابو سعيد
ابو سعيد
مالك بن سنان
ابو سعيد الخدري
comparations
صلى الله عليه وسلم
was
عليه الصلاه والسلام
الخريس
الى خدر
وهو بطن من بني خزرج من الانصار
انصاري
74able
صلى الله عليه وسلم
was
man of
and
the narration of the propet
regarding
the man who ‏had sought out redemption.
He had killed 99 people. He went looking
for a schar.
He turned out to kill people and then
sought for
repentance and was asking for a schar
to direct him as to how to repent.
‏This scholar
not only
directed him to repent and encourage
this but he also
explained to him how to go about
repentance and the most important thing
a person can do when he or she rep or
one of the most important things in
order to sustain that repentance and to
maintain it
is to change a person's
‏to change their place where they
toangecially
people that they are previously with
even if they don't think these people
around them are bad for them if they w a
bad influence then the person would not
be in the situation of needing to repent
from such atrocities and so he commanded
him to go he advised
‏landi
important
place
and
said
فاعبد الله معهم ولا ترجع الى ارضك فانها
ارض سوء
وضبطه بعض العلماء فانها ارض سوء
الله
فانطلق حتى اذا نصف الطريق نصفه نصف
الطريق يعني وصل الى نصف الطريق اتاه
الموت
‏And so went heads this new land to a
new le and when he was
between the land of
wickness and landed
decreed for him to die on that road.
فاختصمت فيه ملائكه الرحمه وملائكه العذاب
ang
الله
قل يتوفاكم
ملك الموت
الذي وكل بكم
الله
nameر
[Silence]
‏name
is name to the ang of men because am
sear itself into the consciousness
even though when weearch it we find that
‏name عزرائيل
ماخوذ من اهل الكتاب في الراجح
ang ملكوت
otherر
الله
ثم توفت
رسلنا وهم لا يفرطون
البراء عازب مسند الامام احمد
صلى الله عليه وسلم
step by
[Silence]
صلى الله عليه وسلم
angousness
[Silence]
‏ang
toct from body
and when the of
the ang of
comes and extracts the from the body and
the prop
say the
angel of death comes to extract the soul
الله سوره الفجر يا ايتها النفس المطمئنه
اخرجي الى رحمه
من ربك ورضوان او ورب غير غضبان
‏come out to beed
by
ang anded
with you and to mery from your
prop
said hearing this the
man's soul will come forth willingly
from the body the last
‏out of a as rolls down the glass to
come out very easily.
He said that conversely
when the angel of death comes to collect
the soul of a wicked man
will say to this soul
and so he will say come out of this
body.
‏and come to
with anger and from
theaty
ك كعهن
كالصوف المبلول من الشوك
‏said ang will
propink
[Silence]
‏if
is
beforeing
of fire and ment
so we understand from this that are
angels of mercy there are angels of
punishment all of them are angels of
death they all work under the command
‏ang
point here areagre
ang of mercy came to take
because of where he is and where he was
headed and the angels of punishment came
because where of where he's coming from
‏and where he has been. And so they
disagreed as to who has more of a right
to take this soul? Is he more worthy of
punishment or mercy? And are the angels
of mercy more of this soul or the angels
of punishment? We will continue this
tomorrow.
وجوده ان يغفر لنا خطايانا نساله تعالى
ان يغفر لنا ذنوبنا وان يتقبل توباتنا وان
يغسل حباتنا وان يسلل
سخيمه قلوبنا انه ولي ذلك والقادر عليه
وصلى الله وصلى اللهم وسلم على نبينا محمد
وصل اللهم وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى اله
واصحابه اجمعين
والحمد لله رب العالمين